Many classes needed to collect objects of another class. Use an array list or
maybe an array for the collecting. Supply a method for adding to the collection
so that it can get bigger over time. And depending on your problem, maybe you
want to have a method from removing items from the collection. You'll want to
supply some methods to find out about the contents. Maybe something that prints
the contents, maybe to test whether a given value is in the collection. That
depends on the individual situation. And here's a bonus tip when you declare
that array list or array, don't forget to initialize it in the constructor.
because otherwise it will be null, and when you add the first element, you'll
get a null pointer exception. Sadly that happens to me a lot. So let's practice
that with another variation of the car class. In this case we want to collect
the names of the passengers. And I've already declared an array list of strings
for you. So that's the instance variable. And your task is to update that
instance variable in a couple of methods.